help is on the way to several hospitals
and medical facilities in Nevada just
overwhelmed with respiratory patients
the governor's office of the state is
going to be expanding Pediatric Services
with RSV flu and covid-19 cases all on
the rise Madison Kimbrough spoke to
several medical professionals across the
valley tonight and she joins us now live
near Sunrise pediatric care with more
with the flu season hitting its peak
medical staff across the valley and
hospitals are struggling the Nevada
Hospital Association calling on governor
sisilak for help
pediatric conditions at Nevada hospitals
are unstable according to the Nevada
hospital association with RSV covid and
flu cases Rising this time of year
Staffing is low and overcrowding remains
an issue and Monday the governor's
office telling eight news now that they
are stepping up efforts to help these
overwhelmed facilities Dr Eileen Shi
pediatrician at little Roots direct
access says she's pleased that help is
on the way I think we need it I think
just in any case just back when we saw
covid and a rise in hospitalization when
you have something so acute for
Respiratory illness is taking over and
affecting so many kids it is a very
labor-intensive area in the hospital
you're going to need your respiratory
therapist you're going to need extra set
of ears according to the governor's
office applications for nursing and
Respiratory Care licenses will now be
fast-tracked since Nevada is a state
that does not accept out-of-state
nursing licenses the state will also
issue a temporary license to any nurse
in Nevada facility deems necessary Lisa
Nicholas assistant professor at the UNLV
School School of Nursing worked in the
Pediatric Care unit for 15 years
Nicholas says while she appreciates that
there is attention being given to
staffing issues there needs to be a
longer term fix you also have to look at
what sort of nurses they're trying to
expedite if you're trying to have the
State Board expedite new graduate nurses
so they can start working that's not
really going to be helpful because then
you have
inexperienced Warm Bodies essentially
just taking up room as opposed to being
experienced helpful nurses that can
actually you know add to the patient
care situation
as for RSV cases the Southern Nevada
Health District reported 1800 cases this
past November that's a 200 percent jump
over the same time last year reporting
near Sunrise pediatric care Madison
Kimball 8 News Now